messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour parler de
cette polémique ou non du vaccin alors
jérôme marty je vais commencer avec vous
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
d'abord la vaccination obligatoire en
cas de découverte d'un vaccin telles
obligations sur un sur un vaccin qui est
qui est nouveau sur vox elle donne
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas grand chose à
mon avis serait donner du grain à moudre
aux à tous les anti vaccins justement
donc je crois que ce qu'il faut c'est
expliquer expliquer l'intérêt de ce
vaccin expliqué sa nocivité tente on le
connaîtra et avoir une politique
vaccinale est digne de ce nom qui fait
que les gens se vaccine rom est passé à
l'obligation alors collé toujours dans
le flou serait à mon avis une erreur
politique sanitaire majeur
rezaï bizarre votre opinion à ce sujet
là oui je partage ce point de vue ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que le vaccin
est là et la stratégie l'outil le plus
fiable pour sortir de cette impasse
parce qu'en gros vous avez en france à
peu près 15 à 17 millions de personnes à
peu près 25% de la population qui sont à
risque par rapport à ceux coronavirus
donc là une fois que vous avez réussi à
protéger en suscitant une immunité
collective au sein de cette population à
risque à travers un vaccin vous avez
quasiment réglé le problème
donc il est évident que sous réserve que
l'on est avec ça qu'ils soient à un
niveau d'innocuité d'un niveau
d'efficacité suffisant il va falloir non
pas par l'obligation je rappelle que la
france et l'italie sont les deux seuls
pays au monde dont on a rendu
obligatoire le vaccin c'est avec le
vaccin devrait est une une stratégie
naturelle devrait être un niveau
d'acceptabilité très élevés comme il
l'est dans la plupart des pays
justement je remarque juste avant
qu'eric bizarre est-ce que ça vaccin
selon vous va être la clé est ce qu'on
retrouvera le monde d'avant finalement
mais personne ne peut le dire
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
s'il ya un vaccin efficace oui on
retrouvera le monde d'avant comme on l'a
avec la grippe et avec tout un tas
d'autres avec juste un point je pense
pas qu'il ya des pro et des anti vaccins
je pense que si la france est arrivée
avec un niveau de l'ordre
30 à 40 % de la population qui est
plutôt hostile au vaccin
c'est pas que cette population elle est
fondamentalement anti vaccin parce que
ça voudrait quand même dire qu'on est
quand même un niveau 2 de radicalité
dans ce pays aussi important c'est que
l'état sanitaire en france est d'une
telle faiblesse qu'on a laissé libre
court à la polémique sur les vaccins et
que finalement c'est ces quelques
radicaux anti vaccins ont gagné la
bataille de manger en partie pour
répondre à frédéric visa est ce que les
anti vaccin n'existe pas ou il y en a
très peu
alors il existe deux types auxerre et on
le voit on le voit tous les jours et ils
sont même assez structuré ils n'ont pas
un raisonnement qui est un raisonnement
est véritablement un scientifique mais
je n'y vais pas pour souvent sur une
théorie plus ou moins de complotiste et
c'était ma mémé le le problème si le
cloud si vous voulez il faut connaître
une politique de santé dit de ce long et
je rejoins tout à fait frédéric bizarre
à ce sens si l'on n'est pas capable
d'expliquer aux gens l'intérêt du max et
emme dans le pays de pasteur
alors c'est qu'il ya un vrai problème
quand on voit que les taux de
vaccination notamment pour des
pathologies comme la rougeole s'est
effondrée ces dernières années on a vu
une réémergence de cette pathologie qui
peut être très dangereuse à la fois chez
les enfants et chez les adultes
ça pose un vrai problème donc je crois
que le vaccin on est rehaussée tous
quelle est son utilité au c'est tout ce
qu'elle est ce quelqu'un serait ces
avantages tant sur le plan sanitaire
qu'économique par rapport à une nouvelle
affection comme comme le govic 19 qui
met à balancer économies mais c'est à
nous tous médecins et politiques
d'expliquer l'intérêt d'expliquer 101
sans détour à la fois les avantages et
les risques d'une politique vaccinale
pour qu'elles soient mises en place et
puis surtout arriver à considérer la
population comme l'être mature et ne pas
faire de paternalisme je remarque si
justement est-ce que vous pensez que ce
vaccin nous permettra d'être
complètement immunisé face au virus
est ce qu'on en sait un peu plus ou pas
du tout ça bien malin qui peut le dire
aussi que cela c'est que ce virus il
mute alors imite de façon assez assez
faible mais quasi tous les dix-huit
jours donc 10e
il se modifie tout à fait régulièrement
on sait aussi que si on fait une
pathologie comme la grippe en ont
instruit le vaccin sur la souche
vaccinale de l'année précédente
et on sait que le vaccin ne protège pas
tout à fait puisque le virus mute
dernière d'une année sur l'autre
donc est-ce qu'il protégera 100% bien
malin qui peut le dire maintenant on ne
demande pas qu'il protège à 100% on
demande à utiliser ce axel pour arriver
à une taux d'immunité qui soit supérieur
à 60% de façon à ce que le virus ne
circule plus ou et de grandes
difficultés à circuler à son malheur au
dtn la contamination
c'est tout ce qu'on demande d'un boxer
frédéric viseur vacciner tout un pays
c'est loin d'être gagné en tout cas ça
prend du temps est ce que la france à
réfléchir à une stratégie vaccinale
c'est une bonne question parce que
l'otan on a essayé de ceux de rendre
disponible le plus tôt possible des
doses en achetant déjà à l'avance des
doses dont vous avez aujourd'hui des
centaines de millions de doses des
vaccins candidats qui sont en train
d'être produit sachant probablement
peuvent pas mal de ces vaccins candidats
ne verront jamais le jour donc là je
pense que la france est assez a été
suivi malheureusement on a perdu notre
leadership pharmaceutiques en europe on
est maintenant le quatrième producteur
d'air en europe alors qu on était
premiers il ya encore dix ans donc on
est plutôt suiveurs que acteurs leaders
enfin on a ce qu'on a suivi les autres
maintenant la question est les lll et
dans la plus tôt dans la réalisation de
cette vaccination dans l'acceptation de
la population ce que disait jérôme marty
par rapport aux mutations de vaccin est
important parce que ce que l'on voit
c'est que le vaccin
trois études sont sortis il n'y a pas
très longtemps serait un train de muter
vers un niveau de contagiosité plus
importants mais à un niveau de
pathogénèse plus plus faible retrait -
ou un virulent
enfin c'est ces trois études là c'est
sorti dans la presse il ya une erreur de
lecture des échos cette étude pilote
d'un ciel est légal est connu depuis
depuis la bad mask la souche vaccinale
en question des dockers à laquelle il
est fait référence dans cet article
c'est la soude vaccinale qui circulent
en france depuis le mois de mars qui a
été découverte le 28
vié en allemagne il n'y a pas de
modifications depuis et c'est plutôt
inquiétant parce qu'effectivement c'est
une plus forte pour un tamis nation mais
absolue dans l'étude il n'est absolument
pas dit que ces moyens qui dira moins de
gravité
il n'y a pas plus de gravité mais il n'y
a pas moins une gravité c'est une
mauvaise lecture de 2,2 de cette étude à
votre votre réponse je vous laisse
répondre non mais juste ce débat moi je
ne suis pas expert je pense pas expert
médical et je veux pas rentrer à temps
mais qui mais qui est l'autorité
sanitaire dans ce pays qui est ce que ce
sont tous les médecins qui vont sur les
plateaux de télé qui commentent à leur
façon les études qui qui est l'autorité
sanitaire dans ce pays c'est la haute
autorité de santé c'est le comité
scientifique on a dû créer la doc dans
le pays c'est le haut conseil de santé
publique
c'est un vrai problème en france c'est
que il est urgent de construire une
vraie autorité sanitaire un vrai état
sanitaire et pour ça on a été sur une
stratégie d' agences ification on a
construit une multitude d'agents ce nom
on l'a bien vu qu'avec cette crise
sanitaire qui est un vrai stress test
pour notre système de santé public qu'en
fait on est démuni d'une vraie auto
autorités sanitaires et c'est d'autant
plus dommageable que donc il ya un
manque de confiance dans la population
dans l'opinion publique sur ce qui est
raconté par les trois meilleurs ce qui
me fait bizarre je me permets de vous
interrompre jérôme marty joue je me vois
le sourire ce cas est-ce que vous vous
pendant une heure
c'est très drôle il a raison la
problématique c'est que donne tout là
d'un tout la première se peuvent appeler
la première phase de la de la pathologie
ou la première vague ce que l'on a pu
constater c'est l'absence cruelle de la
présence justement de la haute autorité
de santé
dc pia cdd c'est à dire ils organiseront
en place est laissée clem pour les
infections nosocomiales un siècle le
rôle de l'autorité de santé et d cclin
c'est précisément la lutte contre les
infections nosocomiales contre les
élections ils n'ont rien fait on ne les
a pas vus monter en ligne et quand il
manquait les masques pour les soignants
alors que c'était leur coeur de cible
pour éviter que que la perfection ce se
propage et on n' ont rien fait ils
étaient absents
quant aux ars le moins qu'on puisse dire
et c'est qu'elles sont allé d'échec en
échec alors c'est réacteurs des pantins
ya des ars qui ont très bien fonctionné
mais l'immense majorité des ars ont mal
fonctionné en tout cas
toute une partie toute la première
partie de la diffusion de l'épidémie
donc effectivement il faut refonder
notre système de santé parce qu'on voit
bien que les bases même aujourd'hui ont
montré dans une période de crise qui est
le moment où on a le plus besoin ne veut
que l on laissait le champ au terrain
qui a pris toute sa place et puis quand
on avait des retours vous savez de
médecins que ce soit hospitalier ou de
ville ils nous disaient tous mais on n'a
jamais aussi bien fonctionné parce qu on
nous fout la paix mais c'est pas un
petit peu budget dorénavant on l'a vu
les milliards pleuvent actuellement dans
la recherche les pré commandes des états
se multiplient la commission européenne
par exemple avec bruxelles a réservé 225
millions de doses potentiel du vaccin
contre le coc u19 de l'allemand cure
vague 300 millions h et le français
sanofi 400 millions pour celui de
l'américain johnson johnson
c'est l'industrie pharmaceutique et
finalement se frotte les mains
mais est ce qu'il voit c'est que c'est
un investissement à très haut risque
qu'un dans les vaccins c'est à dire que
parmi l'ensemble de ses candidats bac 5
vous n'aurez peut-être un deux trois
aucun qui arrivera donc les l'industrie
pharmaceutique à mutualiser son risque
avec les états après la question c'est
de savoir quelle va être la contrepartie
de cette masse très importante de
d'argent public qui est mis dedans c'est
à dire qu'on voit que les américains eux
ont négocié plutôt une exclusivité est
une priorité dans la dent dans l'accès
d'autres comme les européens plutôt eu
tendance à négocier un accès à coup à
prix coûtant sans avoir d'exclusivité
bon donc la question est plus ça c'est
pas forcément une très bonne affaire
pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
in fine et parce qu'encore une fois ce
virus imite on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
si quelle va être la rentabilité
en revanche ce que l'on sait c'est que
sur le plan de la société sur le plan
sociétal
vous n'avez pas plus rentable que
d'investir dans le vaccin
je rappelle qu'un vaccin c'est de
l'ordre de 15 à 20 euros on ne sait pas
exactement celui là enfin on peut
envisager qu'elle va t'elle d'euros et
et le goût d'une une nuit à l'hôpital
en tout cas en réanimation c'est près de
2500 jérôme martin à travers trois
réponses moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
la partie structurelle sur la
distribution du vaccin ce qui pose
question c'est que historiquement c'est
une des premières fois où l'humanité est
soumise dans la même problématique sur
la terre entière c'est-à-dire où les
hommes soit la terre entière connaissent
à plus ou moins ou plus ou moins au même
moment la même problématique
à partir de là on peut se demander
pourquoi il n'y a pas une autorité
supranationale qui va organiser la
distribution du vaccin est ce que je ne
voudrais pas vivre c'est ce qu'on l'a
connue pour le sida c'est à dire que
l'on est des pays africains qui se voit
par exemple par les régimes d'afrique
mais ça peut être pays qu'ils soient qui
arrive au cac cède au vaccin
beaucoup plus tard que les autres pays
parce qu'on a la même problématique
au même moment on est tous des hommes et
puis que la vie d'une personne en
afrique ne vaut pas moins que la vie
d'une personne en europe merci
infiniment à vous deux pour ce débat
passionnant merci à vous deux encore
merci à jérôme marty je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste et
président du fnl et frédéric bizarre
merci à vous également je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste de la santé
président institut de santé merci à vous
monsieur